each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
well thank you very much let me follow
on a little from what John how he opened
his taught by saying that as a I started
off as a chemist with a bit of biology
background who was interested in build
databases and I guess fast forwarding 20
30 years where John was I basically was
asked to develop a course in
bioinformatics and that was probably in
the early 90s and in contrast i would
say that course has changed quite
significantly every single year in a
field that's moving very very fast it's
also a very interesting field and it's
encouraging to see that there's so much
investment and interested in that in
Colombia because it's something that can
actually be done in a way that requires
relatively little resource it's also a
field that actually depends almost
entirely on data that's generated from
others and so this notion of the
openness that's needed to advance that
field is in some way a driver for what
I'm going to say so that's sort of it's
not going to be a talk about
bioinformatics so you can breathe a sigh
of relief there it's really drilling
down on some of the things that Tony
said with respect to open science so my
essential message then is if I pick up
on Rick said this morning as if it
researches the insurance policy of the
future then open science and open
research is a way to maximize the return
on that policy so so I'm coming to you
as a domain scientists with a belief
that this sort of openness is absolutely
critical to our future and the idea is
we need to Mac and we need to embrace as
many scientists worthwhile as worldwide
as we can and indeed I figured I would
commend Microsoft for actually being
very forward in this way of thinking
but my sense my hope then is some of you
will leave this unmet that you would
leave you'll see this unmet need in
achieving open science and be motivated
to to the contribute more well I'm
telling you of course is a very biased
view and I think it's very important to
identify the fact that each domain is
different and how each domain operate is
very different so there's a certain
sociology associated with each domain of
science and I think what we need is this
combination of Technology and
recognition of that sociology to
actually move forward and I'll
illustrate that with examples from the
domain that I know best of course which
is it's biology I have a certain bias in
what I'm telling you and I think it's
important they tell you that bias
because that will tell you whether in
fact you should believe what I'm saying
I suppose I actually maintain a
well-funded resource and I'm going to
use that to illustrate what I'm saying
and I say well funded because you know
there's if I'd done surveys other people
have done surveys and what we see out
there is the persistence of information
is very very poor so the idea that we
have a well-funded resource is an
exceptional case I want to make that
point I've actually been involved in
developing open access journals
particularly with what's called plus the
public library of science I just want to
say what I mean here by an open access
journal because we'll be coming back to
this notion there are different metrics
of open access but I'm really going to
be talking about is the idea that the
the information is freely available
provided you attribute the original
author and that information is in a form
that can be used by machine and that's
to me an extremely important aspect and
it's not what most biologists think of
when they think of open access open
access they think free to read and
sometimes there's a misconception that
they think it's also of lesser quality
because essentially you're paying to
publish they don't think there's really
any instance in biology at least to
support that notion
I've also believe it you know you can
talk about open access and it's in
subway a very liberal way of thinking
but I've also add that I'm an absolute
believer there must be a business model
associated with this otherwise there can
be no persistence and then lastly just a
sort of in a sense to reveal myself I'd
also you know have a company that deals
with scientific dissemination that uses
open access content and these kinds of
models I'll get into a little but let me
just say a little about the protein data
bank which is a worldwide repository and
I'm going to use this to illustrate my
points it's actually a worldwide
repository of the three-dimensional
structures of protein information this
is not important particularly to the
talk there's not a drug that's been
discovered in the last 20 years that
hasn't used this resource so it's
actually a vital resource the biology
but what I want to point out which is
kind of relevant to this discussion is
that it's actually a community resource
the community is the ones that own this
resource they feel they own it they
gather in a virtual way around elements
of data within that resource and use it
as such as an open resource so it's a
very important community and
communication mechanism for this
particular branch of science another
aspect of it oh I point out is it's only
one terabyte of information there's this
notion of I think too much attention
this is these are all personal views
that's paid to very large data sets at
the price of what I would call a long
tail where there's a large number of
researchers that are actually producing
relatively small amounts of information
which is not actually considered in the
way it should be so curation and funding
for support of that data is not
necessarily forthcoming it's all in the
bigger data sets and this of course is
not in itself a big data set it
somewhere I guess semi big
so what came out so so what does working
with a resource like this in biology
tell me about open science well the
first thing it told me several years ago
in fact probably six or seven years ago
when I really started thinking about it
and also starting and running a journal
was is a database really different than
a journal these are something that are
perceived as being very different and
we'll get to this in a minute because
it's a key part of the sociology Tony
actually touched on it with respect to
reward but here is something that in
technological terms is really no
different whether it be a database or a
journal what's very different is the
perception of the value of that
information if I publish a paper and
science or nature that's going to go a
long way towards tenure if I stick a
dataset into the PDB it's effectively
not going to count for anything now you
know we need to shift these norms and
I'm going to say a bit more about that
just to sort of focus you as computer
scientists on what we actually see
happening around this kind of data which
i think would I would hope would guide
you into thinking the kinds of things
that you could do with big data or with
data in general is that what we've
observed this is a resource it's
probably the oldest resource in biology
goes back we're actually having the 40th
anniversary this year is that the user
base has continued to broaden so there's
about 200,000 users a month now
including an increasing amount of
students in high school and below and
also in in the general public so I think
actually creating things that enable
those particular audiences audiences the
better use the data is something that's
happening what the internet what the
sort of web to our era has brought to us
i think is more people from a broader
spectrum using quite technical data i
think it behooves us to create tools and
mechanisms to now you enable them to use
that data if much more effectively
and I'll give you an example of that to
me which is quite striking in a minute
there are other aspects which I'll touch
on but things like which are more
technical that clearly there's a much
bigger demand for accessing data not
through the web web page directly but
through web services this is a sort of
prevalent thing we're seeing mobile use
is increasing I mean these are not
necessarily surprises and also the use
of web 20 communications so so what am I
thinking we need going forward well let
me just say the points right now and
then sort of come up with at least some
ideas of what some solutions might be
science is increasingly digital but
whether it be driven by observational
hypothesis I think we've heard a lot
about that today science is a
complicated workflow but how we
communicate science I would argue in
some extent is still still embedded in
the 16th century I think the current
publishing paradigms in large part are
really just delivering PDFs which in a
sense is just an electronic way of
delivering what we were delivering
hundreds of years ago we're not using
the power of the medium and you know in
a general sense of course three examples
where it's powerfully used but if you
look at the field in my case of in
biological sciences it's a slow moving
process of change so sort of parts of
this is that too many and that analog
steps in this whole process still I mean
it's absolutely certain absurd as a
trivial example but when you publish in
most biological journals that you take
an Excel spreadsheet which ultimately
goes to a publisher over a wall
effectively we're a point they returned
it to the consumer as effectively in
analog for it's not in the original form
where you can actually use that data so
it's a trivial example but it's it's
it's stuff that's going on our current
workflow tools in my view are grossly
inadequate for supporting the digital
scientific enterprise
are elements that really work well but
they don't necessarily play well
together and they're not complete and
I'll show you some more of my thinking
on that in a second we have a lot of the
components already to build the twin the
21st century printing press if you like
but they're not really well put together
and they're not used by publishers very
effectively if at all so these are sort
of you know things that are happening
but what's interesting and what's
exciting is that really changes afoot
the game is afoot and some of the
drivers of that change and tony alluded
to this a little that when i have a
graduate student who comes in with a
very first paper they're very exciting
they've drafted this paper will sit and
talk about it for half an hour on
whatever and i realized in the time
we've been talking about it probably
fifty papers have been in the index by
pubmed which is the main aggregator of
bioscience content and actually put out
on the web not just the abstracts so
we're generating 1.2 million papers per
year currently so clearly and these are
the number of interactive searches that
are done on that data clearly it's
totally out of hand in terms of being
able to keep up with even your most
tiniest sub-specialty at the same time
in biology we're seeing an enormous
growth in the number of online resources
something like 1300 just beginning of
this year so this is huge wealth of
information and as my colleague Cameron
eons that talks about this it's not so
much that the information is a problem
it's our ability to filter and I think
we heard about that from John a minute
ago in terms of actually being able to
return most meaningful results with
respect which has been you know in
ranking which is one form in essence of
filtering at least in my native way of
thinking so I think I want to illustrate
why the change changes afoot with a cup
of examples that I think a quite point
at least they are to me
I think this is true of certainly of
what I learn about computer science is
that the actual publishing process could
be horribly arduous and law in biology
it's probably significantly shorter but
it's still actually totally unacceptable
and by saying by the time the paper is
published we could be dead is not
necessarily an exaggeration so what
happened during the h1n1 outbreak is
that it was impossible to get
information studying that virus based on
the normal process of publication it was
just too slow so various aspera things
emerged and here's just one example that
the public life science actually
developed what they call currents the
influenza currents which is where which
was similar to what Tony talked about
with the archive where information
effectively papers that we published
later were actually deposited in this
archive straightaway is this great yes
it was great at the time but what
happened when the pandemic was passed is
that that momentum of deposition into
that resource effectively stopped so
here we come to the sociological aspect
in a time of crisis people did respond
and actually forego the traditional
publishing process but when that was
over they fell back to the old reward
system and that's what I'll be saying a
bit about in a second just to illustrate
this at the top right hand corner here's
a is the graph of the growth of the
number of h1n1 cases in United States
and down below is actually two data sets
that were that are in the protein data
bank that relate to h1n1 what you can
see is that there was very little access
and as soon as you know the outbreak
occurred and over a period of time there
was a very significant out access to
this data set these data sets very
surprisingly it as we did when we
surveyed a significant amount of that
access was from the general public
so there is growing awareness and using
of online scientific data by the public
is is an interesting phenomenon I think
and this notion of community science and
so forth as in examples of that but let
me sort of give you one final example of
the motivators for change which actually
comes from an individual and his name is
josh just summers and essentially what
happened is that in 2006 he was a he was
actually diagnosed with something called
chordomas disease he was at the time he
was actually an engineering freshman
first year at university at duke
university so what happened is that when
he found out he had this disease he
immediately was in the hospital still
and he essentially wanted to try and
find out what what was wrong with him
well he would mediately had a barrier
because he could get a certain amount of
information from things like wikipedia
and so forth but he could read
scientific abstracts for the most part
he could not gain access to the deep
information that he needed about this
disease and so what he did finally learn
that probably he only had seven years to
live that's the general prognosis for
this disease the treatment for it and
the drug regimes are extremely the drug
regimes are very poor the radiotherapy
is extremely evasive so not a very good
situation ironically so what could he
done he could have just gone on from
parted for seven years but no what he
decided to do was devote himself to
actually working on this disease and
indeed what happened ironically the only
NIH the only us-funded researcher
working on core doma disease in the
United States was actually it is his
university so he gave up engineering and
he went and worked in this lab to try
and actually move things forward he
actually founded the core DOMA
foundation with his mother to actually
this is to annual meetings they've had
to try and accelerate the process of
this disease what he described in his
and it in his learnings about this was
first of all what's generally known by
anybody who works in drug discovery is
that it's essentially an enormously
arduous process typically 15 years and a
hundred and eight hundred and fifty to a
billion dollars to actually put a new
drug on the market and a lot of that
sort of the mid point of view a lot of
that time is spent by the current
research enterprise which is really very
very inefficient is that you have a
series of labs and operate who are
interested in this disease they don't
even communicate very well within their
own group okay I say this is an
embarrassment true that in my own group
of about 25 people is that we don't
actually communicate as well as we
should we don't have the tools for the
kind of communication that we really
need and then there's the issue of
actually communicating with other labs
and the time frame all of that takes so
the idea and there's now what's called
the commons which is a series of efforts
on things like disease modeling to
actually bring this data openly and all
the information as quickly as possible
to be shared by the researchers and in
the public domain so this is for this
point of view is paramount because from
the time that they started doing this
the people are circled this is already a
year old so what the situation is now I
can't say that I've already died so you
know it's actually gaining access to
this information so I think at least for
me that's a lot of motivation to try and
help as a biologist to try and help move
things along so what are the issues and
I want to illustrate the issues and then
illustrate not great solutions but just
sort of a few things that we and some
other people are doing to try and
restless because I think they could
certainly feed into how this audience
could contribute so it all has to do
with balance and the tipping point so
right now we have the right things to do
on 15 side of the scale and on the other
we have reward well the sad truth is
right now in the academic enterprise at
least you essentially get rewarded for
papers and grants grants can easily be
translated into money yep and that's
really where the soul rewards lie the
idea of making data available actually
reviewing in that sense is something we
do but there's no real reward for it the
provision of metadata open access
curation and so forth alternative forms
of disseminating our information and new
tools don't get the kind of reward that
they really deserve and will see that
there's a sociology associated with that
which I think we have an obligation to
change so how could we have we make the
system better well there's a
prerequisite and I'll just illustrate
Tony already touched on this and I'll
just sort of illustrate it with my own
particular experience is that in
nineteen ninety i wrote this book which
actually did pretty well but it was at
what actually happened because it was
about unix is that my name is born i
must have been asked thousands of times
whether i was in fact Steve born who
wrote the bourne shell well I'm not if I
had been if I got a dollar for everytime
i said i had not i'd be a rich man I
wouldn't be standing here okay but the
point is that the in my own field that
someone with the same name same initial
and his first initial so there's this
issue of disambiguation and we need to
sell them my case I need the Borno
density right I need I need that that
unique identifier this is important and
you know and it's actually happening
Tony mentioned orchid and orchid of
being a DOI digital object identifier
for people i think is an excellent
solution that I I think we would at
least tell you i would agree it's
probably going to
really make a difference and the reason
it's important is just like a DOI allows
you to resolve the unique reference to a
piece of scholarly work the the orchid
identifier and principal will allow you
to resolve the whatever given scholar
has done the point is it's important for
research work and research papers and
publish work but it's also important for
absolutely everything you produce all of
your scroll the output which includes
not only papers it includes things like
posters but blog postings reviews you've
done all of the all of these elements so
we until we can uniquely identify your
scholarly output in cyberspace we can't
actually start crediting it so it's a
very important first step but sort of
actually coming along but already the
licenses to lay enable this to be
managed properly so I think it's just a
matter of time before this will actually
take place when it does take place we
will have a very different environment
in which to measure scholarship and to
actually use scholarship here are just a
few examples we saw actually some of
these in a different context from John
about how we actually measure
scholarship currently so in the top left
there there's a network diagram and
that's a network diagram that can be
generated by in different ways but what
it is is it's effectively the author and
all of that person that the author has
ever co-authored with so the thick of
the edges so each each node in that
network is an author and each edge is
the thickness of the edge is a
representation of how many different
papers they publish together we use this
now routinely in hiring not as a
decisive tool but certainly as an
informative piece of informative
information and if i look at my network
that's apology of my network against
other people in my department who have
actually published around the same
number of papers i actually see quite
different clearly i'm a grumpy old man
who actually publishes with the
relatively few people and therefore i
have a small number of nose with thick
edges where as my colleagues have a more
flourishing network i suppose but so
that you know that tells you something
no I think Microsoft of academic search
is an excellent tool but at the moment
as with all of these other tools it's
impossible to get to do anything
accurately which is just crazy because
we are we think in terms of accuracy and
yet we measure ourselves in ways that
are totally inaccurate and so here's an
example of where the change is starting
to come in that I think we can begin to
build on so this is just something this
is just a paper clearly this idea of the
orchid is somewhat controversial a lot
of scientists I want to be identified as
a number so at some point wrote a small
piece that essentially was titled I'm
not a scientist I'm a number it got a
lot of normally when you do these kinds
of things the commentary you get you'll
get a lot of commentary around blog
postings but on scientific literature at
the present time it's almost considered
sacrosanct at least in biology and
people do not comment on publish work
except when it's something as
controversial as this but generally
speaking it won't happen partly because
graduate students are scared to do it
and you know and/or there's no reward
there lies the biggest problem all there
is no reward for doing that but other
metrics are coming this is from the
public library of science and you can
see that that bottom graph shows you the
number of downloads of that paper it
doesn't mean to say necessarily that
that paper is valuable but it's probably
telling you more than the impact factor
of the journal itself which frankly
tells you absolutely very little about
that particular article that's in the
journal and what I did is a sort of goof
which got a lot of attention in this
thing was essentially to design a
scholar factor and so a scholar factor
is effectively the age factor
which is a standard measure which is
quite useful no question it only speaks
to a small part of the scholarly output
some MNH factor of 30 it means i
published 30 papers they've been cited
more than 30 times but that's only part
of the story so then i have grant
manuscript reviews and so forth that i
can annotations i'd make of software
depositions the databases all the things
that a scholar in biology does which I
just came up with a crazy weighting
scheme to come up with an overall
scholar factor and so you know what came
of this is a lot of discussion and I
think that sort of thing is good we need
this kind of thing because the impact
factor doesn't do the job and what we
need to do is it's a way of educating
the community about what's important
because I think it's absolutely absurd
but when I am reviewed or I'm actually
reviewing people I sit on these
committees but literally there could be
half a dozen of us who are deciding on
someone from whatever purpose promotion
tenure but probably only one to two of
the people on that committee really know
what that person is doing what are the
others do they me that you go and look
at the publication list they look and
see what the impact factor of those
papers are and make a decision based on
that and that is really just not
adequate so we really need to improve
this situation and one of the ways to
improve it is 24 is for academics to
actually inform the people who are
reviewing them who may be thinking
differently about this that these are
important metrics so this is what's
going to drive openness forward I think
is when people realize that it's
important what's going on here it's it's
actually scholarship that actually
should be crediting so all right so
that's a lot of preamble there so what
we want to do then is we want to get to
this tipping point so we want to move
some of these things across from the
left to the right so it's more than just
being ident it's actually making them
happen so how do you so how do you get
let's thought about data availability
there's no reward right now
for effectively for making dates are
available but we should change that and
I think data providers have any enormous
responsibility to do that so what we
should do is a big database provider is
really to support that so effectively we
should define metadata within our
communities that really make sure that
the provenance is actually fully
captured and is made available and we
should do that collectively so I could
immediately go and pull all of the data
resources that Phil Bourne has actually
deposited data into I can see what they
are I can see how much that that data
has been accessed and consequently that
would actually define in some way a part
of my scholarship so this this falls
with the data resources so in terms of
what we're doing just as a very small
contribution we're already providing do
is four components of data so they can
be resolved clearly what we need to do
is we're orchid becomes established we
need to make sure that the deposit of
that information have orchids associated
with them and you know we essentially go
from there so it's really up to the
scientists to do that so that's just
sort of as it goes to date I'm not going
to go to all of the aspects of the
tipping point but let me just cover a
couple more so open access is another
one so what's interesting there is that
things are changing so I've SAT there in
presentations from young biologists who
say I just submitted this paper
yesterday if anyone is interested in a
copy I'll send it to you by email well
that is actually something that in
biology was unheard of ten years ago I
can remember as a postdoc when I went
and works in a lab we actually made
metal models of proteins as before
molecular graphics we would actually
have a device that would actually dial
in angles and we create a backbone of a
protein as a wire model my p.i was so
paranoid that we had labs on either side
of a corridor at Columbia University I
was not allowed to take that across the
corridor without putting in a bag in
case someone saw it and got some
information out of it I think things
really changed and said why is that I
don't have answers for this but I can
make some possible suggestions I think
just the the whole attitude around
social media and E professionalism as it
relates to using those media and how
students and young faculty are actually
projecting themselves around these media
is very different makes them makes them
think differently I think another
certain major contribution is stuff is
happening so quickly data has been
generated so quickly as we've heard in a
number of contacts today that the the
incremental value of a piece of data is
much less so people don't regard it in
quite the same way generational I think
the influence of other fields that have
been much more open for much longer and
of course as we heard from Tony in terms
of the NSF and NIH data data policies
there's now pressure to do this there in
various forms so all of those are
possibilities and again I'll use just a
metric from our particular database that
illustrates that it is indeed happening
in quantitative terms and that is we
have different kinds of release strategy
when people put data into this database
there you can actually release it
immediately you can hold it until the
publication about that data is is is
actually published or you can hold it
for a period of time up to one year or
you can see from here that all of this
that has changed it used to be only ten
percent released immediately now it's 50
and so there's much more openness around
this information so these are all good
sociological changes that we can
certainly try and build upon the other
aspect is that is how this all
interfaces were the literature or what
was traditionally in the literature I
think there's no doubt through efforts
of which the public library of science
and BMC the biomedical biomed central of
pioneered in the life sciences that open
access of the literature is i would say
going to a number of publishers meetings
is essentially in the life sciences are
done deal
it's all a matter of time there will be
holdouts of journals actually transcend
disciplines and obviously can hold out
in terms of the pay model what's
interesting is that the parallels to
what's happened in newspapers if you
look at what's happened in the United
Kingdom around newspapers it's an
interesting parallel so I think what is
happening here and that is to say if you
look at the Times of London they put up
a pay wall to prevent people getting at
their content unless they pay and they
lost ninety-five percent of their
subscribers in the first week and they
have not been able to get minute most of
them back on the other hand the Guardian
newspaper which tied into the New York
Times which is also an interesting
possible change but the point being is
that at least for now part of their
model is to actually leverage free
content it's all about adding services
to that free content and I think that's
what's so important to biology as well
so it's about leveraging that content so
where does all this take isn't only
began to describe this and let me just
sort of paint a picture that takes it a
little farther than we actually have
right now so what we're talking about
here is the idea that we have much
greater integration of the data and the
knowledge about that data and associated
metadata than we have today so what does
that mean well in this flow diagram here
essentially on top right hand corner you
have a paper well nothing unusual there
except now that paper is just one view
on that collective set of information ok
so I could actually have multiple views
the next step is the notion that I can
what you do now I can click on a
thumbnail in that in that paper and I
get a figure blown up alright what I can
do already on the internet is i can
actually in this case it doesn't matter
these about molecules you can think
about in whatever context you like but
that figure of course only tells me so
much what i really want to do is to be
able to render and
and analyze and do things with that
figure now I can actually already in
some instances go automatically to the
database which is in this case happens
to be the PDB and in fact one of the
biggest users of our web services is
becoming the publishing industry they're
pulling that data back the problem is
that what they get is not exactly what's
in that paper that paper has a series of
thought processes that went in by the
authors to create that particular
orientation that we wrap for you which I
can't recover directly from a database
right now what I need is I need the
metadata associated with that generation
that allows me to create something
that's identical to what I had what's
there and then I can learn so much more
from that of course what I should be
able to do is I play around with that is
I should be able to actually annotate it
on my own comments that it should also
be able to see annotations that others
have placed on any aspect of that work
again what's the room that's not
necessarily a reward from doing that but
it's actually how and it could be
private could be within the group it
could be public but it's a way and some
of this is happening it enables me to
actually learn more but also I've used
that information as a visual cue and
then as I go on to step three by using
that visual cue I actually click on some
aspects of that figure because of that
cue that then gives me a mash-up of
information so maybe it's a loop on this
protein structure that's somewhat
unusual well I can now do is I can mash
up information from the literature and
from other databases that's actually a
reflection of other information that's
known about that particular in this case
loop that visual cue and so that then
drives me back round to say another
paper or some other information and so
the cycle continues so what I've done is
I've actually got a much more intuitive
and interactive working environment that
integrates a lot of things together that
currently for the most part at least in
biology is not possible so these are the
kinds of things
I'm very interested in seeing happen but
you know elements of them exist there
already but I think there are some
stumbling blocks again though stumbling
blocks are not so much the technology
but that's the bit of the sociology so
clearly we have examples of crowd
annotation we have examples of data and
knowledge interoperability you know we
have interactive papers and we have sort
of also the part that I didn't really
mention this is a very active community
of researchers who are in the process of
reinventing the what I would call the
printing press and it into label all of
these things to happen so let me just
give you a couple of examples from the
work that goes on in the PDB just to
give you some illustrations of what can
happen on how sort of it's actually
low-hanging fruit a lot of this stuff so
what it's a it's a good case scenario
because there is a body of literature
typically a paper or more that's
associated with a with a discrete set of
data that's very well defined so this is
clearly the best case scenario but in
many areas of science doesn't exist so
this is the best case this doesn't mean
anything but I just want to use it to
remind me to illustrate a point all
right and the point is what you can do
with open content that you can't do with
close content so here is here is that's
what's a piece of data in this case it's
a structure right and essentially that
has a paper associated with it and that
paper has citations so I can see as the
producer of that data I can see
everybody who's actually used my data
who cited it well that's useful but hey
guess what most people don't actually
cite that data now they don't cite my
paper when they're using my data just
the fact of life in biology but what
they do do so people can at least get
some level of reproducibility is they
include the identifier for that data set
that was useless before but now
now if the all of the information the
paper itself is open access this is not
about text mining this is trivial
passing of the complete open access
corpus of biological information I can
immediately find all references to that
structure in the in the open access
literature that's the good news the bad
news is that literature probably at the
moment only comprises about fifteen
percent maybe 20 now of the full
literature in this field but it's useful
the other thing it tells me is it tells
me not only where that data was used but
it tells me what other datasets appeared
in the same paper and so I can see
correlations between data but I would
never be able to get because I can never
look at that million papers that were
indexed you know that this this just
this past year so it's trivial stuff but
it's or its to a biologist it's a very
powerful development that requires open
access to that literature and so you can
go on and you you can look at it from a
literature viewpoint now and it's just
example there are a number of people
doing this is just an example so we've
taken all of the open access literature
that's in what something called pubmed
central in the Biosciences and we've
essentially done semantic tagging on it
and some we've actually applied
semantics to it so as tony alluded to
the field is rich this field is rich in
ontology and descriptions so effectively
what we do we have this the view of the
the pay-per-view but immediately we see
all of the ontological terms that have
actually been referenced in that paper
and we have a set of rich semantic tags
that allows us to bring build semantic
associations that we didn't have
previously and we can pull up data from
the databases and all that kind of stuff
which is what this is another aspect of
all of this which to me is under
underutilized at the moment and I maybe
I just don't know what I'm talking about
but it seems to be something that's
enormously useful that's really not
being used and we're actually again I
think as providers of information as all
of us are is we have a responsibility to
actually provide these
kinds of tools so these are just a set
of example widgets so essentially they
allow me to do something on on data
that's in our particular database that's
particularly useful of course is that
they're they're trivial to develop so
there's no excuse for not doing them and
they provide a very powerful set of
tools just like just this again this is
not just to me to remind you to tell you
something but for example there's
reference there two Cotton's named
Wendell Stanley and essentially let's
say in a paper or on web page or
something and effectively we have a very
simple mechanism to immediately go in
query in our data resource all instances
of Wendell Stanley's depositions to that
data resource as it so I don't leave the
context of what I'm reading but I'm
using you know simple mechanisms through
web service calls and some very simple
scripting to actually get information
from these resources and this idea of
you know of sharing and using
information this way is something in
biology at least we haven't really
adopted very much and yet I think it's a
very powerful way you can imagine where
you create workflows from these these
instances of these widgets but allow you
to do some very very powerful things
with essentially very little effort and
we're not really seeing enough of those
at this point it's just another example
of this semantic tagging I won't go into
it it's not to say that publishers
aren't doing this elsevier has a thing
called article of the future where this
is this sort of thing is starting to
happen but what's been really successful
is not what the publishers have done
it's what the grassroots efforts of
scientists who are increasingly
frustrated by the lack of tools and
awareness of this this is just something
called utopia which is essentially a PDF
marker approach that does semantic
tagging does a number of the things I
mentioned on the fly of biological
literature so it's a relatively simple
minded thing but it's really caught the
imagination of scientists in the field
now because they don't actually have to
do anything they just actually read the
document instead of in a PDF viewer they
use a utopia viewer and so that this is
just an example of raising this
awareness and really starting to help
push this tipping point to a much much
more usable set of information and all
of this is the idea that what we're
doing so far with utopia and these other
things is post-processing the literature
but we really want is to do this at the
point of authoring and so the kind of
things that Tony was talking about with
chemical markup and you know some other
tools that we've been working on with
Microsoft in the past is the idea of
actually doing for example semantic
tagging at the point of authoring all
right the tools are there to do this
kind of thing the technology is there
it's it's the semantic version in my own
simple-minded view of the spell checker
as I type it doesn't just correct things
it suggests semantic tags that I should
use to my information that are based on
say ontological references or pseudonyms
or other things but I can use the
semantic tags to semantically limp
information together from different
sources and create a much more rich rich
rich and navigation medium so it all
seems very logical the technology is
there so why isn't it all over the place
well the problem is the publishers in
this case are very reticent to actually
adopt these kind of tools so part of the
issue is you know you have a business
model that's been very successful why
would you want to take the risk if if
there's any semblance that this is
actually more effort to the author maybe
they'll just go and publish elsewhere so
the idea that publishers will adopt this
you know there's a negative side of it
but the fact well you know I'm going to
lose business on the other hand you know
you could say if you actually fast track
the papers and said okay if you actually
do this will actually make sure your
paper goes through the system gets
reviewed faster all that maybe that
would be a carrot enough but no one has
taken that plunge so it's an example
again the technology is there
but the sociology and the business is
somewhat behind in my view just to bring
this to sort of the logical conclusion
and she jumped up stood alumnus here's
another sort of example of this that is
such low-hanging fruit but such value
it's hard to ignore so each of these
nodes in this network is actually it
could be anything but it's actually
these are actually genes ok let's just
say their genes and any edge is
essentially where and the thickness of
the edge which don't come out very well
is when those two genes appear in the
same publication all right so there's
some association there now obviously
this network has a topology and when you
start overlaying other properties on to
that that network some very obvious
things emerge which are actually very
powerful so it turns out that that set
of nodes up there on one side of the
topology happened to be all in
references in the immune literature
that's regarded as part of the
immunology community this happens to be
people who are part of cardiac disease
community what's interesting of course
is this gene that's right here in the
nut middle but pleased to have some kind
of duplicate function within those two
domains now it's quite probable that the
cardiac disease folks have no idea about
this because they don't read this other
literature I mean they might find it by
Senate serendipitously but you know
frankly a being or a google search is
not going to find it you know deep
search which is another aspect of all
this might actually find something in
some associated databases but this is
just an example of a give away from this
kind of thing so here we have another
example of a push across that if there's
reward for it it could actually happen
so I just want to talk a little about
dissemination because that's another
push all right i mentioned that we're
very poor at really disseminating our
content we're still stuck in the 16th
century so to speak this is from about
four or four years ago now i walked into
my lab and therefore graduate students
actively working away typing away with
headphones on i'm thinking this
his research at its best i can go off
the car lahaina and enjoy myself where
they're working away but when i look
more closely of course all four of them
were actually watching youtube so
immediately I started thinking well you
know why aren't we making more use of
these media in science and of course at
that time this is several years ago you
go on to youtube and the very first
thing I found because you type in your
own name as you do to see what this
video for UCSD for my university and the
very first thing i sees yes there's my
little thumbnail with my video
associated with it and immediately under
it is for nude men and i look at this
one of those nude men this is a way
author disambiguation would work better
if we didn't have it was disambiguate
was a big whatever it is but the point
was that one of those people was an
Austrian new dance company one of those
people heaven's name happen to be feel
born well I didn't really want my
science associated with that kind of
thing so we went off and developed a
whole bunch of things but the idea was
to be more to actually take advantage of
the medium so the idea was the first of
all it comes back to the sociology
you're not going to get tenure for
making a video okay you're going to get
tenure for writing a good paper the get
cited a lot so maybe there's something
in between maybe if you get the authors
to actually make a video about the paper
and you integrate that with the contents
of the paper so as they talk about the
appropriate parts of the paper they pop
up on the screen and this kind of thing
maybe that would be a selling point if
you could convince the the authors that
they would do better by doing this and
in fact we've shown that if you do this
it has a number of connotations right it
actually is another entry point into
that paper that is indexed in various
ways and this codes consequently found
so you actually get people more people
find your paper and more people
understand the paper because first of
all you had a one minute abstract that
you would read if you dug in it was us
three hours to get into this paper but
he was a 10 5 or 10-minute succinct
overview of the paper by the authors
seems great
so the other plus was you could actually
be reading the paper you didn't have to
be watching the video and you don't
understand a certain aspect of that
paper you click on it and that pops the
author and starts immediately telling
you about that little piece of the paper
okay well it sounds great right did it
work no why partly because it was very
hard to convince that the first of all
the original notion was that the
graduate student would flip open their
laptop and in a few minutes they would
make this representation in fact I made
a whole group of students do it and some
very interesting things happened as an
aside first of all very smart kid here I
won't go into his name and song but very
shy always looking down I thought he's
going to be terrible at this he'll be
absolutely tell he was actually the best
person he was so it was so extroverted
in front of the camera where he's so
introverted normally yeah my graduate
students said we're going to be a group
of news car of science casters you know
this changes the way we can vary science
for the fact is it doesn't change it at
all because if you want to be any good
at science you've got to get up on a
podium and give a good lecture about
your work anyway so this is just doing
it in a different medium the problem is
of course is that there's still no
reward for this but that's starting to
change I mean journals are now starting
to include video content with their
papers that are integrated in with the
paper so this these are good things at
the same time some very other
interesting and exciting things happen
that work that we didn't even conceive
of in the beginning so while this didn't
really take off with papers it's taken
off with posters because posters have a
different connotation but basically the
graduate student is usually left to deal
with a poster and so you can do the same
kind of thing as having it a student
talk about their poster and you created
some level of persistence relative to
something that's up on a meeting for a
day or two and then goes and sits on a
wall in the laboratory where no one ever
sees it this creates something somewhat
different it's also created excitement
in science if you watch so in originally
in groups that we didn't expect but
k12 with in high school in high school
students / university students is that
essentially they've taken on to this and
basically produce some incredible things
that really do insight other students to
do the same kind of thing and raise
awareness of science and so forth so
this you know and of course all of these
are open and so it's you know these are
these are valuable things and this is
just sort of where where the things gone
and I won't go into the details of that
so at the end of the day what we've done
is we're trying to push all of these
things over to so that the some reward I
haven't talked about tools and other
things but you know we've got a long way
to go this I mean what what I think
doesn't exist is to some degree is the
tools at least some tools exist but we
don't really have enough integrated
tools to really push this thing across
and and it's like I've said several
times we the sociology and Technology
are not really well mapped together so
I'll just close with describing what I
see is the problems and hopefully you'll
provide the solutions to some of this as
I see this as an experiment as an expiry
'used working in this domain so we we
don't have as I said before good
solutions all the way through so here's
the sort of typical pipeline that one
would assemble to do you know any kind
of science as you basically start off
with an idea that gets into a hypothesis
you do an experiment so there are data
management tools there then there are
things increasingly in the cloud that
are quite useful but still they fall
short they're not customizable they just
don't allow us to do the kinds of things
we need to do in our own scientific
disciplines then if you actually are
analyzing and maintaining data and you
need a laboratory information system
again specialized systems but not things
that are easily tailorable for different
environments and then I think perhaps I
feel at least currently a little
different with okay you suddenly have
this
data then what happens to it yes there's
this notion at least that this data is
well catalogued somewhere and we'll all
be able to share it will be indexed and
all the rest of it that I don't have
personally and correct me if I'm wrong
but I don't have a lot of faith in the
current mechanisms that are doing this
I've been in the US the meetings of
institutional repositories where they
talk about these things that I've
actually been quite disappointed at the
moment I think things will change I'm
disappointed because there doesn't seem
to be any standardization it doesn't
seem to be any notion of what the
metrics of a success of these things
should be and they don't you know and
there's not the interoperability and so
forth is not there and then at the other
part of this of course is this notion of
when we get to the publishing the fact
that right now the publisher is as a
discrete from the whole process that
goes on to produce that publish material
there's no reason why that should be so
in the end of the day you actually take
all of that scientific endeavor and you
actually put it into some form that
meets the needs of the publisher and yes
it's a useful one form of review by that
by a reader that there are many other
forms that could be produced which are
lost by virtue of the fact that
currently I would say that the the
current bulk of publishers either
incapable of doing this well they don't
want to change based on their business
models or they recognize the issue but
they don't have the resources to
actually make those changes so we're
kind of in this sort of stopped point
right now and I think it you know a
really good tipping point from my point
of view would be the set of tools that
go along this pipeline and allow us
really to get information out there in a
variety of different ways that satisfy
our particular audiences so that I'll
stop well thank you for your attention
and I won't read through this is a
stance or academic talks there's a whole
group of people there they've all been
fantastic but I won't
into that and so you know thank you very
much